au blanc mesnil l'on l'appelle la cité
du 212 7 cités d'habitation à bon marché
l'ancêtre des hlm va être protégé par le
conservateur régional des monuments
historiques
construite dans les années 30 c'est un
exemplaire unique mais cette mesure de
protection suscite une polémique avec la
société qui la gère elle voulait en
détruire une partie pour la réhabiliter
ce reportage en seine-saint-denis de
valérie war et mark salling 1933 la cité
du 212 sort de terre c'est l'une des
premières cités hbm habitations bon
marché juste en face
l'aéroport du bourget est en plein essor
et il faut des logements
aujourd'hui la cité intéresse les
monuments historiques comme un très beau
témoignage du passé pour les
spécialistes c'est l'un des meilleurs
exemples de l' influence de l'
architecture socialiste viennoise des
années 30 sont conservés parce que c'est
beau et que ce set historiquement
importance dans les souabes architecture
c'est un moment deuxième chose des gens
y vivent
il faut voir maintenant il ya des
problèmes que sont posés par la vie des
gens dans cet ensemble car la cité bien
délabré entre vandalisme et d'insécurité
chez les appartements se vident des
logements trop petits 33 m² en moyenne
la société hlm de les relous plus la
moitié des 500 logements sont murées en
attendant une réhabilitation se ficher
sept s'étaient regardés en vie comme des
prisonniers avec du béton à ce que c'est
une vi pour la jeunesse pour tout le
monde
impossible de tout rénover trop cher la
société hlm veut détruire une barre sur
deux pour aérer la cité et faire des
appartements plus grand mais aujourd'hui
elles se sont prisonnières des monuments
historiques projet de classement nous
interdirait le démolir quelques
bâtiments que ce soit et donc de créer
la situation
ce qui nous pose un gros problème il
faut savoir effectivement choisir entre
la préservation des bâtiments et puis un
certain nombre
d'objectifs d'objectifs sociaux elle
devra maintenant négocier avec les
monuments historiques qui se disent
ouverts au dialogue
problème c'est pas pour nous c'est pas
vous conservez exactement en l'état il
ya des choses
d'apparence qui sont à garder on ne va
pas garder des apports points qui sont
manifestement trop petit les habitants
espèrent des travaux très vite mais pour
eux le 212 est déjà rentré dans
l'histoire il sature ça ça prouve que
c'est un monument historique quoi ouais